so the last is how to run a process and
Demont really is deep in this all the
time so what does a typical fundraising
process look like for founder's how many
investors would any given founder need
to talk to to close their round yeah I
think when founders hear what a standard
process looks like and then when they
actually experience the actual process
it's a it can be a bit daunting but in
general we see a successful fundraise
has a founder talked to looking at let's
say at the top of the funnel 150 or so
VCS and we talked earlier about targets
targets yes targets prospects if you
will for in a sales process and we
talked earlier about how to tell if they
are a good target for you and so then
whittling that list down a bit but then
ultimately these are qualified targets
though you're saying 150 qualified
targets not just dumping a database and
saying I have 500 VCS I'm ready to go
sure you have to qualify the 150 most
targeted through your business they're
not investors in common headspace or
that's right a competitor or they have
they do consume or not just enterprise
yeah but you're not just randomly
dumping a crunchbase scrape into your
funding fun yeah and you know we
generally recommend our companies
starting with the the starting with
Silicon Valley investors or kind of the
top investors in kind of the major Geo's
those are the folks that have the most
experience growing these companies are
the ones that's going to be more help
most helpful so again when you're
talking about that 150 the ones that
you've qualified those are the sort of
folks that we want to we push our
portfolio to we like to think that we've
picked great portfolio companies and we
want them to get the top 10% of
investors right anything wrong with
getting the mid-tier I mean it's they
can be if you can get the money it it
usually works it can be it can work out
ok as a founder you may not get as much
help you may not have as many intros it
may not you may not get the next round
may not be as easy as getting a brand
name right but oftentimes when you go to
that mid tier or lower you often get
jerked around a lot in the fundraising
process itself
so let's professionalism yes just people
that you know get a little too excited
promise a little too much and ultimately
can't can't deliver on those promises
maybe they're the bottom third and in
the mid tier maybe behaves a little bit
better and top tier sure paradoxically
you think the top tier would be the most
buttoned up yeah there you might even
think that they were would be more
complicated but they turn out to be less
yeah in general they have they have a
process they they've done this a lot of
times they understand that a founder
today could be very different from a
founder you know a year from now they've
seen many mistakes happen and misses
happen and so they're trying to make
sure that every interaction that they
have is a positive one 150 at the top
where do we go now so next we would try
to get intros into probably around 100
to 125 of those folks you want to try to
stack those together as much as possible
and then from intros we typically we
typically see founders doing about 75
meetings so whether that's in person or
initial phone calls right from there you
know kind of whittles down to kind of
second meetings ultimately you hope to
go into diligence with around 10 firms
and then through diligence we still see
a drop-off and typically we'll see you
know three of those firms ultimately
participating in the round so you're
talking about 2% 1 or 2% of the people
you actually have a conversation with
will participate yeah
and that can be frustrating for a
founder especially as we see them sounds
like a full-time job yeah and that's
what you always say it's a full-time job
yeah it's the time where you have to
delegate you have to have to get out of
the day-to-day business of your business
and you have to focus on fundraising Wow
it's also why we recommend that you in
your in the round that you're in you
raise enough money to cover at least 18
months of runway so you don't have to
turn around and do this again because
it's rough yeah it is so weird that
people raise enough money to go for six
months or nine months why not raise
eighteen months of runway have a great
plan to get you to those milestones and
have a plan being a plan C if you don't
hit those right that's because people
don't have a plan being a plan C they
have a I'm going to the top name venture
firm and I'm just
gonna get five million dollars or ten
million dollars what I will say is
amazing is that I think the companies on
our accelerator tend to get two out of
three meetings they try to get mm-hmm
what would a an on launch accelerate or
an on Y Combinator company what would
their hit rate be on email
intro to actual per a meeting yeah I
mean the the reason our companies have a
much higher conversion on email to a
meeting is the quality of the intro so
it really has a lot to do with that and
obviously because of your background and
success rate an intro from you is well
respected and so thus we have a higher
conversion rate so when it's a lower
quality intro or a cold email you know
those those percentages can be 10
percent five percent or so right on on
the conversion somebody listening to
this in Boise Idaho their startups doing
a million dollars they come to Silicon
Valley after emailing a hundred 50
people that they pre-qualified you know
they might only get 5 10 15 meetings yep
so you got to be super realistic and
this is where the validation that a Y
Combinator tech stars or launch
accelerator actually matter it's not
it's to to our own horn but if you find
yourself getting less than 10% you know
intro to meeting you might need better
intros yeah and the accelerator or again
to our own horn it's a hack it's a it's
a it's a shortcut hack to get to where
you ultimately want to go faster and you
have to trade some equity for that but
we most founders don't regret yeah it's
sort of like these you get into Stanford
or Harvard it's the same hack exactly
people just automatically assume if you
got into Harvard or Yale you had to be
smart you had to struggle to get in
there little do they know you just
photoshopped your picture onto a
lacrosse player and your parents gave
somebody four hundred thousand dollars
to their nonprofit it's not fair alright
listen this has been a great episode we
went a little bit long but this is the
first of ten if you want to get the deck
that we went here and we're gonna have
some links in there to it go to this
week in startups comm slash scale this
will get you the deck for
all ten of the episodes were doing all
10 of the videos and links to backup
material because we may have mentioned
some backup material like a safe we
might link out to the safe document or
if we mention a founder who's been on
the podcast and might link out to a
podcast or a blog post Thank You emmy
award-winning producer jackie our
managing director of education she'll be
on one of the upcoming episodes thank
you managing director Ashley from The
Syndicate and managing director Jason
Dumont from the launch accelerator we
will see you all next time on this week
in startups bye bye